[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so networking minds is important because
it unlocks solutions that you would
never come up with by yourself and you
would also miss with other like-minded
people so the idea is if you can pull in
the brainpower of diverse points of view
if you can harness cognitive diversity
you can build solutions build companies
build outcomes create new ideas that
otherwise would be unavailable to you
and the people immediately around you
there are different tools to network
Minds just like there's conversation
about what is open innovation how do I
collaborate and I'll outline a couple
[Music]
prize competitions are not new Charles
Lindbergh won a prize for flight
margarine that fire extinguisher there
are lots of different things that came
out of old school prize competitions the
new thing about price competitions is
the online platforms and forums so I can
put out there hey I have $500 if anyone
can solve my problem there's the prize
or a thousand or 50,000 or the XPrize
there's a huge you know prize
competition there's a company called
InnoCentive that rolled out of Eli Lilly
and this is for solving pharmaceutical
drug problems originally all of these
individual companies are trying with our
own scientists to solve disease problems
and InnoCentive Alf Bingham said no
let's have a big platform for seekers
and solvers those who are seeking
solutions and those who are solving and
there's research showing the farther you
are away from this expertise the more
likely you are to solve these problems
so the kid in Romania the 15 year old
yeah
that might be the brain power you need
to solve a problem that's sitting at a
pharmaceutical company in Boston for
example online collaboration and
awarding prizes has a bunch of reach so
if you want to network minds
prize competitions one way
[Music]
a flash team is a project team you can
come together work on one project and
then disband this is enabled through all
the online communication that's that's
out there in different ways you can pull
the engineer for one project our lynard
is a company out of Harvard Business
School recently you can hire a nerd by
the hour to be a consultant for whatever
project that you have that you need to
solve and these flash teams the idea at
a big company like IBM we're seeing
across the entire company people come
together in their smart cities
initiative for a couple weeks and then
go back to their traditional job a flash
team can come together solve a problem
if that working arrangement worked well
many of those people will want to come
and work together again if it didn't you
disband and go on with life and go back
to doing other teams but this is enabled
very much as an online collaboration or
networking of brainpower
[Music]
so a third way that you could online
reach out and grab you know smart minds
is through the gamification of work so
you can build a game and not just for
entertainment but for solving a problem
or building a product if you can make it
fun you can often get a lot of other
people to play and in the playing of
games together you build trust you build
relationships and you can crack problems
so an example there out of the
University of Washington is fold it so
this is a protein folding game it's much
like Tetris and human beings can see in
three dimensions so this is a
three-dimensional game the computer just
Big Data things cannot see three
dimensions as well so University of
Washington set up a game saying hey help
us fold these proteins and figure out
all these different things and people
played the game against each other and
in two weeks they figured out one of the
protein folding things for the replica
replication of HIV it had taken years
and no one had figured that out so in a
game format harnessing minds from across
the globe to play a game these
scientists have solved part of a problem
that they want to have solved
[Music]
if you think about physical space space
can be a lever and this is really
important in the room that you're
sitting in in your office or in a
classroom if it is one person standing
in front and lines are rows of chairs
that is a one-to-many model and that is
not networking minds that is one mind
going forth and saying what it knows if
you instead configure space to be round
tables of three or four or five people
and vertical use of walls if you write
on walls three or four or five people
can see that and people can brainstorm
and solve a problem together if you
write on your own little notepad in
front of you as we have with traditional
education and in business note-taking
everything else only one person is
really saying that so if you want to
harness the brainpower of more than one
person and certainly a group of people
use three-dimensional space
use small configurations of people use
different office cubicles are not
networking Minds right figure out how
you can use space as a lever to
influence other people to bring their
ideas forward
[Music]